a
ah
[Música]
la verdad que yo pensé que en una
película
y pues cuando me dijeron que era una
plática ted decidí tomar este reto
decidí venir y pues platicarles de mi
historia mi triste historia completa
yo no sabía la magnitud de pues de ted y
pues ahorita sí que miles y miles de
personas están viendo esto y la verdad
que me siento bien contento de pues de
decir mi historia y puede compartir
todos mis experiencias a pesar de mi
corta edad tengo muchas experiencias
todo comenzó cuando mi abuelita veía las
películas de pedro infante es como son
los abuelitos no hay un novio y no es
tiene un carisma y cantar hermoso y mi
novia y mi novia hay dejé por eso es mi
abuelita no no sé las de ustedes pero le
encantaba pedro infante
y pues yo empecé a ver pedro infante me
gustaba como cantaba me gustaba como
actuaba ya después mi mamá me vio que yo
quería cantar como él y que yo cantaba
con mi abuelita en medio ese talento
decidió meterme a clases de canto a mi
corta edad no me podía meter porque
tenía como cuatro o cinco años y pues
por mi corta edad me decían que no pues
hay para la otra
y pues no no tenía la oportunidad de
meterme a clases de canto pasaron como
dos años y fuimos a una fiesta
y de repente le dijeron a mi mamá no es
que hay un maestro en purísima del
rincón muy cerquita pues que es un gran
maestro y así no y pues yo tenía yo
tiene sensación de meterme yo estaba
emocionadísimo porque por fin me iba a
meter a clases de canto no luego viene
mi abuelita mi mamá y llegamos con el
maestro no hay alguien contenta y le
dice el maestro a ver a ver quién de los
tres va a cantar la abuelita la mamá o
el niño y pues el niño bien chiquito no
estaba demasiado chiquito yo le dije no
pues yo me dijo y cuántos años tienes y
ocho ello de mentir ayuda ya yo tenía
como seis años vi poste me notaba lo
chiquito no me creyó pero yo le dije que
ha hecho y se me dio esa gran
oportunidad de meterme a clases de canto
no de hecho mi mamá se metió conmigo a
clases de canto y mi primer escenario
subí y estaba como hace ratito bien
nervioso
no sé por qué estaba nervioso pero ya
cuando estoy aquí se me quitan los
nervios y pues poderles compartir mi
historia pues es un gran honor en mi
primer escenario fue como que mucha
adrenalina de que si me equivoco y si
esto y si me caigo del escenario como
con gabriel
y pues sí estaba con ese nervio pero ya
cuando estaba en el escenario como que
me transformaba no sé y me decía al
maestro me decían mis compañeros de
clases de canto me decían cómo le hace
es muy doméstica tomando un tequila acá
bien fuerte para para agarrar valor y
pues yo cantar me unas cancioncitas de
vicente fernández
el globo pues el chiste que yo les dije
pues no si yo me transformo yo como que
si yo cambio en el escenario no y pues
es el chiste participé en bastantes en
bastantes concursos de canto
participe en pequeños gigantes participe
en la academia kids participe en
infinidades de concursos de canto y pues
no quedaba el primer concurso de canto
pues ya era hora
yo llegué y no tenía mucha experiencia
tenía como un año cantando yo llegué yo
bien feliz porque pasé en aguascalientes
eran como dos mil tres mil niños y eran
bastantes niños y pues gracias a dios
pase y a la primera vez puso sal
empezamos con el pie derecho
y llegué les gustó mi voz y me llamaron
a mexico asi que traían niños del df de
león guanajuato de monterrey de ciudad
juárez de sonora de hermosillo de de
muchas partes
y pues desgraciadamente no quede me fui
súper enojado súper triste y yo soy muy
devoto de san juditas tadeo yo tenía una
imagen de él y de repente llegue la
venta y paz - y pues yo mi mamá me dijo
y por qué te enojas con el cine te hizo
nada y habrá más oportunidades y habrá
infinidades de casting ya tendrás toda
la oportunidad y las cosas pasan por
algo
mi mamá es muy sabia y yo le agradezco
mucho a ella por todos estos años
y después vienen conmigo la actuación
viene conmigo la actuación a mi mamá le
llaman y le dice no pues queremos a su
hijo para un cortometraje
porque no la vida pues es para afrontar
retos porque no fuimos y pues yo no
sabía nada la actuación y pues para
haber sido la primera vez les encantó mi
trabajo y pues yo de ahí dije yo quiero
actuar
y actuamos en guanajuato
san miguel de allende en dolores hidalgo
en confort y en lengua los gatos les
encantó mi trabajo y yo estaba súper
emocionado de ahí yo quise meterme
también a la actuación todo un pedro
infante
increíble no y la verdad que son
experiencias extraordinarias después
viene luis felipe tovar a león
guanajuato un hombre con un carácter
bien el cual es libre pero me dio
consejos increíbles no como por ejemplo
si en esta vida no te preparas no eres
nadie son consejos que te da ese hombre
pero tiene un carácter
y la verdad que son experiencias
hermosas yo fue cuando me metí a clases
de actuación y me encantó la actuación
pero yo también me quiere enfocar el
canto y no lo deje no deje el canto y
pues viene
muchas cosas vienen acá viene academia
kits viene muchas cosas y me metía y no
quedaba y me metía y no quedaba y no se
me daba la gran oportunidad y de hecho
pues si nos trataban así como que
digamos que aburrir qué bárbaro no
porque pasábamos y te ponían en 1843
y pues así como que el básico te pasabas
y te quitaban el número 88
si te tratan re bien
y la verdad que sí se sentía muy triste
porque no quedaba y no quedaba y no
quedaba yo trataba de buscar pues ese
logro no yo trataba de buscar y algo
pues para hacer yo no ahorita quién soy
yo y no quedaban me ponía muy triste y
nueva dijo no te preocupes vendrá la
gran oportunidad
hemos sufrido bastante no fue nada fácil
llegar hasta donde estoy mi mamá fue muy
criticada le han dicho de cosas de que
tu hijo te va a dar una patada por la
espalda te va a dar te va a dejar en un
asilo de ancianos y pues todo eso no y
yo le dije porque si ella es la que me
está apoyando todos estos años y es la
que ha estado detrás de mí no y pues si
yo sentía muy feo y yo dije les voy a
demostrar que yo voy a poder
y pues tiene la oportunidad de la
búsqueda me preparé bastante me empecé a
preparar con infinidad de canciones yo
le dije a mi maestro no yo quiero
participar no pues pero en para el otro
y siempre pues te piden dos canciones y
dos tipos de género una reacción al
mexicano porque ellos son de las que
tanto hay una pop
y pues yo no te apoyo pero yo no es mi
estilo
yo no no es mi estilo
infinidades de niños mi mamá siempre en
todos los castings se han formado como
de dos de la mañana a una de la mañana y
aún así hay miles y miles de niños
enfrente de ella
y se agradece mucho a ella
siempre nos hemos ido un día antes mi
abuelito en ese día nos llevó nos llevó
un día antes y nos despertamos como a
las 2 de la mañana y habían niños
adelante
me invites y muchas personas muchos
papás se quedan a dormir ponen una calle
en la calle sus casas de campanillas de
chocolate y tita la cosa y hasta la
cuadra llega yo toda vez doblando y así
allá y por si son infinidades de niños
no pase
pues me escogieron pase los dos filtros
de 1500 niños nomás salieron 10
increíble y de sus 10 fui al afortunado
pero yo nunca pensé que de esos 10 iban
a mandar los vídeos a la ciudad de
mexico aquí
pues iban escogiendo más a 3.500 niños
nomás a tres niños y pues gracias a dios
y al afortunado de pues de todo mexicano
es algo increíble
si fue súper difícil llegar hasta allí
pero dije se me dio la gran oportunidad
de estar en la voz que siempre lo había
soñado estar en un programa de
televisión antes de eso ya ves que los
coaches
antes estaba súper nervioso y estaba ahí
para que si estaba súper nervioso y
hasta cuando me paré en el escenario y
dije voy a dar lo mejor de mí voy a
voltear los tres coches no nos voltean
los tres y me decidí por en marne y
mijares marcas y me fui con ellos es una
experiencia increíble porque con los dos
artistas como emanuel y mijares como
maluma como rosario y vas pasando por
los pasillos y te cuentas a cada actor
no tengo que entrar sacar como que allí
es actuar de alguna telenovela desde y
mi mamá pues es muy fan de las
telenovelas así que hay que seguir lo
ves y somete la foto y ésta nos tuvieron
que quitar los teléfonos
nunca en mi vida no había subido un
avión y en la voz kits me subí y son
experiencias increíbles y lo que más te
duele de salir ahí
lo que más te duele es que a lo mejor ya
no vas a convivir con tus compañeros oa
lo mejor ya no les vas a poder volver a
hablar así no vas a tener sus contactos
de ellos eso es lo que más te duele o a
lo mejor también te duele que ya han van
más todo pagado y pues ya no te van a
pagar todo eso pues también esto
y pues también duele cuando más te gusta
una persona
me gusta una niña pero bueno eso
después mi mamá de y la voz que ya
manejaba agenda
y me acuerdo en ese día
y teníamos una presentación le hablan a
mi mamá no queremos a su hijo para una
película así que el otro no me dijo nada
pues está la otra
a mi madre que te dije entienda gloria
si no pues que me hablo pixar que una
película ya y yo y que les dijiste
nosotros que no que para la otra
un 20 es la gran oportunidad de pues
todo el mundo trabajar en una película
de pixar que ha ganado miles y miles de
oscares que ha estado en toy story en
monsters inc en karts en infinidades de
películas increíbles y mi mamá les dijo
que no pues hay para la otra
y pues si yo así como que me
me puse súper triste y mi mamá dijo no
te preocupes mi viaje llega la
oportunidad bien tranquila mi mamá
bueno mi mamá es super sabia y a la
semana me hablan me volvieron a hablar
como queremos a su hijo o bengasi sino
ya con tiempo
y mi mamá les dijo sí
siempre todos los años ahorramos para
los libros y para las inscripciones de
la escuela y ahorramos es el chiste
y nos fuimos con ese dinero de los
libros de la escuela la ciudad de mexico
hacer el casting y estaba súper nervioso
porque si no quedaba de donde sacamos el
dinero y oliveira la escuela tal vez sí
pero de donde sacamos el dinero
y que estaba súper nervioso porque
tampoco sabía
cómo hacer doblaje de voz tampoco sabía
que me iban hacer o que iba a cantar no
me dieron nada nada nada para estudiar
nada y así como tengo que hacer
llegamos y pues estaba súper nervioso y
había un niño a delante de mí cantaba
voces de chiquillos y cantaba muy bien y
yo le dije a mi mamá no manches maya me
ganó ya estoy al otro y pues sí me puse
bien nervioso mi mamá me dijo no te
preocupes cuando te tocan ni aunque te
quites
ya no bueno pero acuérdate que vas con
el dinero de los libros ay madre ayúdame
y pasen al camerino pase al estudio
grabamos y les encantó mi trabajo y que
de dónde viene ese niño de donde me lo
trajeron de la voz kids
me preguntaron y ganaste es como que no
me dijo nada pues no te preocupes
siempre los primeros no son los que
sobresalen ya no entre y pues gracias a
dios quedé en lo de la película de coco
fueron experiencias extraordinarias de
estar en una alfombra roja
con muchas cámaras gael garcía y marco
antonio solís angélica maría y cuando
ves la película por primera vez con tu
familia y más pasión que mi mamá dijo
y de veras de la voz o si soy yo
pero son experiencias extraordinarias
bueno a lo que voy es lo dice la
película
lo dice ernesto de la cruz y ahora lo
dice luis aquí como escalonilla vive tu
momento muchas gracias
[Aplausos]